نبدا من روسيا حيث افادت خدمه الطوارئ
باصابه 45 شخصا في انفجار في مصنع في
منطقه سركيف التي تقع شمال شرقيه مقاطعه
موسكو ونقلت وكاله تاسع عن خدمه الطوارئ
الروسيه قولها ان انفجار مستودع عند
الالعاب الناريه تسبب في انفجار مصنع
لمعدات تصوير ومراقبه واجهزه طبيه ومخبريه
نافيه ان يكون الانفجار ناجما عن هجوم
بطائره مسيره وكانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
قد اعلنت احباط محاوله اوكرانيه لتنفيذ
هجوم بطائرتين مسيرتين على العاصمه موسكو
وضواحيها من ضاحيه
موسكو تنضم الينا رانيا الدريدي رانيا ما
الذي تسبب في هذا الانفجار وما الذي نتج
عنه
بدايه دعني اقول ان عدد يعني ضحايا هذا
الانفجار قد ارتفع الى 52 جريحا 14 في
حاله خطره سته منهم في حاله الانعاش واود
الاشاره الى ان عمليات يعني الترميم لا
تزال قائمه وفي ظل الاعلان عن امكانيه
وجود يعني اشخاص لا يزالون تحت الانقاض
وعليه فان عمليات يعني البحث عنهم وانتشال
الدمار لا تزال قائمه حتى هذه اللحظه فيما
يتعلق باسباب هذا الانفجار وفقا للمعطيات
الرسميه فان هذا الانفجار وقع في مخزن
مستودع للالعاب الناريه هذا المستودع يقع
في منطقه المصنع مصنع البصريات الذي يقوم
بتصنيع العدسات المخصصه
للمختبرات لالات التصوير والمراقبه وما
الى ذلك هذا المستودع يقع في منطقه المصنع
هو شركه خاصه قامت باستئجار هذا المستودع
من هذه
يعني من هذا المصنع من اداره هذا المصنع
والانفجار وقع بحسب المعطيات الرسميه سببه
عامل بشري عدم
الاستخدام غير السليم للتكنولوجيا تسبب
بالانفجار في هذا المستودع هذا الانفجار
طال المصنع وايضا تسبب في انفجار في داخله
اذا يعني هو حادث سببه عامل بشري ووفقا
للجنه التحقيقات الروسيه فقد استبعدت ان
يكون هناك اي رابط
لامكانيه ان تكون مسيره هي التي قامت
بتنفيذ اي هجوم على يعني على اراضي هذه
المنطقه
الانفجار طالما مساحه بلغت نحو 1600 متر
مربع
تسبب والحق يعني اضرار ماديه بعدد من
المباني في هذه المنطقه
ومحيط ومحيطها واود التذكير بان هذا
المصنع يعمل منذ عهد الاتحاد السوفيتي عام
1935 وبالفعل يعني يمكن القول ان هذه
المنطقه سيريا فصاد التي نحن نتواجد فيها
هي منطقه سياحيه يعني معروفه في روسيا
وبالتالي فان مثل هذا الانفجار يعني يمكن
القول انه تسبب بضجه هنا على الصعيد
الداخلي في صفوف المواطنين الروس وحتى هذه
اللحظه اذا عمليات التنقيب والبحث عن
الجرحى لا تزال قائمه ولكن بشكل عام يمكن
القول ان انه شيئا فشيئا يتم احتواء اثار
هذا الدمار اخماد الحرائق تم منذ ساعات
عده ولكن فقط عمليات التنقيب لا تزال
قائمه حتى هذه اللحظه شكرا جزيلا لك من